hallo mein name ist luca und ich bin ein
weicher aber da ich ein youtube den
verkauf ich mich und will das machen was
ihr feiert deswegen greift freddys zwei
ich habe bisher unter anderem auch den
ersten teil gespielt das will ich euch
jeder solltet ihr vielleicht vorher
anschauen damit ihr vielleicht wisst wie
scheiß sich in dem spiel bin nur jetzt
habe ich mir gedacht dass ich das ganze
tatsächlich noch mal mache im zweiten
teil ich weiß nicht was anders ist aber
viele meint luca es gibt so viele teile
und du spielst a4 an den aero mein gott
wo bin ich denn hier gelandet er hat
viele berufe mich wieder an ich habe
hier einen schacht und ich habe rechts
einen schacht und tirol
ich habe dies in die maske was sie tut
weiß ich nicht ich habe rechts im bild
schön und alle drei sind noch da
tatsächlich das ist ja super also kann
es auf jeden fall bleiben ich fühle mich
trotz so ein bisschen wie bei paper toss
hier unten sind wir könnten teile und
ich muss die irgendwo da haben wir
wirklich alles anschauen wo wir auch
mein gott was ich dachte wer schon eine
ausgebrochen hier aber wir haben
eigentlich noch alles hier ja genau
alles noch da ich habe gerade einfach
abgedrückt um die dingsda lasse da rein
zu klappen ich habe das spiel beendet
herzlich willkommen auf meinem kanal
abonniert mich doch vielleicht für mehr
da sind wir wieder weg zurück am start
im game ich habe einfach auf continuo
geklickt ich weiß nicht ob ich jetzt
immer noch da bin oder
ja es sieht so aus als ob ich immer noch
hier wäre hier unten haben die komische
maske was bringt diese scheiß maske
alter kann es sein dass teil 2 einfach
komplett bescheuert ist und überhaupt
ich besser als teil eins so will jeder
dass ich den spieler hier ist doch hier
ist spürt das ist kacke wollte
eigentlich auch eine pizza ich hab' ich
habe einen pizzaofen geschmissen
ich wollte nur mal schauen wo auch alle
sind noch daran
zwei oder drei 104 wieso spitzenreiter
sind doch viel besser
wahrscheinlich sind als in normaler typ
der sich denkt was ist wenn das spiel
horrorspiel buch dieses video nennt sich
so was müssen das für horror spiele hier
oben haben wir einen flash lite button
da sieht man wohl wie voll wie sobald
diese scheiße ok eine person ist weg
jetzt wird ein bisschen ernst jetzt
gerade das heißt bimmelt hier wir sehen
ich sehe ist dass dieser kleine polster
da ist der eine und da ist der andere
displays tempo dahin da ist das entlein
ich habe an mein gott mein schrank
wisst ihr was ich konnte es gar nicht
schaffen
ich muss mir mal ganz kurz umziehen weg
ins theater
ich habe einen luca shampoo die an und
jetzt ist es möglich dass ich das
schaffe ich habe am sonntag geburtstag
und wenn ihr das video sieht es
wahrscheinlich gerade samstag das heißt
morgen könnt ihr gibt es 1000 signierte
sticker 1000 autogramm in lucka shop das
heißt morgen ganz schnell bestellen wenn
ihren sticker oder sticker mit autogramm
von mir haben wollte und dann könnt ihr
vielleicht einen kriegen und der holy
ist einfach so bequem alter das wollte
ich nur sagen das ist quasi mein
geburtstagsgeschenk zum 21 geburtstag an
euch
ich schenke ich euch quasi 1000
signiertes ticker und da hab ich vier
stunden angesetzten die ganze scheiße zu
unterschreiben schau mal ich kann sogar
wenn ich in den räumen bin hier ihre
taschenlampen oder erhard creepy aus alu
ich kann mir im raum die scheiße
benutzen die dunklen ecken rot leuchten
ihr was ich meine was spricht denn
theoretisch gesehen dagegen dass ich
einfach mal die ganze zeit hierbleiben
mit dem monitor ist das ein bug oder
oder wie das kann doch eigentlich sein
oder ich kann die ganze härte mit meinem
schatz monitoren auf den leuten hier
weiter brown schon kann die ab und zu
mal wenig bock habt ihr die taschenlampe
drücken und sehe wie hässlich die
aussehen und wie
mit hochwasser
was soll das
1 weg wir haben die person da ist das
ist ja toll manstein das vielleicht gibt
wobei ich ja dabei ist da wir haben den
einen cam 7 hier und den anna mein gott
wir vorne die musikbox kann ich noch mal
eben wieder auf kurbeln damit hier ein
bisschen musik ist sauer wir haben euch
beiden immer noch im jahr die letzte
person weg ist freunde habe ich ja
action combat familien ich weiß nicht ob
diese maske bringt ich will doch ehrlich
gesagt nicht rausfinden ist ich bin
nicht gemacht für horror spiele ich will
nicht dass jemand einander bei kuka
lieder vor als es faktisch oft
vielleicht großer hin wo seid ihr wir
haben jemanden term 0 1 wir haben
jemanden in da direkt in cham 0 6 m
der ist im schacht direkt ich meine das
ist ja immer so eine sache mit dem
horror spielen auf der einen seite bin
ich die machen um ihr selber zu beweisen
dass ich es hinkriege nicht direkt
auszuflippen aber auf der anderen seite
ist mein herz hat einfach das einfachste
herz was es gibt und ich
ich bin die gemacht für horror spiele
machen wir weiter damit ich muss hier
vorne wieder die musicbox aufladen
das mache ich mal direkt jetzt werde ich
jetzt gehe ich wieder in die cam 09 und
es sind tatsächlich alle noch da das ist
ja wundervoll meine damen und herren
seit dem ich diesen pulli an habe ist
meine facebook total überbelichtet weil
sie denkt ja mann der so geil der hat
sogar in virgin den müssen wir auf jeden
fall besser putten und beleuchten oh
mein gott ich sehe gerade da ist hier
ist gerade ich muss hier wieder die
musicbox aufladen und wenn wir wieder
zurückgehen dann käme einer weg wir
haben ihn in cam
drei haben wir ihn und wenn wir wieder
in kambodscha ist die ente ist auf weg
wir haben die enten cam 7 und ihn in dem
drei und müssen dann einfach mal warten
ob die irgendwie sich noch verpissen wir
haben den ausgang 0 9 verloren und er
steht in dem zehn in camp hope lauft ihr
dann immer so dumm durch die gegend ab
musicbox klicken haut geht
und da haben wir eine camp 4 einen incam
wo sind die anderen flughäfen die
spieler haben wir hier eine ecke einer
stetter vorne direkt hier wieder schön
die musikbox auf um danach direkt wieder
in meine bude zu gehen und zu sehen dass
der bastard da vorne immer noch steht
mit seiner komischen kaka in der hand
den rest haben wir in chemnitz 1 und 0 2
das heißt wir müssen uns quasi noch im
hier fokussieren so dass er mir nicht zu
nahe kommen teilte der rechten zeit um
eine taschenlampe wenn er da im spiel
für die maske aufsetzt auch mal die
kapuze auf weil ich traue mich immer wie
ich will dann immer auf mein handy cook
monaten beantworten spiele spiele ich
die kacke denn auch um halb eins mitten
in der nacht
schlagerspiel nie wieder hoch